what's happened now it is and it happens
all the time is you've forgotten about
one point when you're going to the next
one so when you go to where me you've
actually forgotten the point of the cuta
gosh and that not the Leaning
um but you've forgotten also the
blending so so what's happening any kind
of guy I said about his hand and I said
you just leave them on a little bit
while you move yes and what's happening
around me now is we've gone here and
you've sort of jumped in he stands still
while I do this jump
all right
have he smokes he could have smoked
about five cigarettes
so
look I said about this
leading didn't I yeah by the time it
gets I'm sure Navy the first flowers
the body turns
they're very difficult you know I'm not
just giving you stuff for the sake of it
the same old same words
where
it does that
I now need to give him a little boost
because I need a spark if we had a box
of matches and I had the match here as I
do that and see the head of the mat goes
I need to feel that I'm the match head
[Music]
I'll give him a little little
boom live
so the car guys I was leading leading
him on a little bit
but now I'm gonna actually give him a
little pull
but I'm really pulling myself
I attached to him and that ejects me
behind me
that's why it's such a complicated with
our eyes
because uh
you have to know when to instill little
points and I know it's far beyond
perhaps a lot of you but at least if you
remember you can go away work on it and
one day you'll go oh I remember we said
this over here now you've got to do a
friend huh laggy is floating
believing
next time